SALVATORE SFERRAZZA:
Hey, everyone.
In this video, I'll talk about
the challenges of analyzing
market data in a
traditional environment
and how CME Smart Stream
with Google Cloud could help.
Risk is defined as a situation
involving exposure to danger.
When it comes to
the topic of risk,
trading firms are inherently
sensitive, especially
in current times where global
systems are all being impacted
from market volatility.
They manage risk by
collecting signals
from a diverse
set of data points
and interpreting them to make
timely business decisions.
One key source of
these data points
is CME Smart Stream, which
delivers a real-time feed
of financial and
commodity market data
that traders can use as an input
to inform a risk management
strategy.
First, an introduction
to CME Group.
CME Group runs exchanges where
futures contracts are traded.
For example, a corn
futures contract
guarantees a farmer
that at harvest time,
they'll get a certain amount
of money for their corn,
and guarantees a
processing plant
that they'll get a certain
amount of corn for their money.
The contract price is
the price of certainty.
These contracts
work the same way
for corn, oil, or even stock.
To get indications of
risk, trading firms
working for the
parties constantly
monitor live contract prices.
To do so, exchanges
traditionally
send each change in
a contract's price
to a trading firm's data center,
requiring significant resources
for data storage and analytics.
With CME Smart Stream,
that same price data
is delivered in real time to
trading firms' Cloud resources.
We selected three
personas that care
about the firm's overall risk--
a risk manager, an
infrastructure engineer,
and a data scientist.
Let's take a look at each role.
First, the risk manager.
Volatility and
information asymmetry
injects uncertainty into
the firm's decision process.
Timely standardized
market data can help,
but the traditional methods
for receiving such data
are oftentimes
costly and complex.
In contrast, Google
Cloud attaches directly
to CME Smart Stream to store
large data sets in our BigQuery
backend and allow analysis
through a plethora of options,
including standard SQL.
When combined, risk
managers easily
get the visualizations they
need while paying for only
the resources they use.
And as a result, there are
afforded a real-time view
of exposure that can help them
adjust positions and mitigate
risk promptly when necessary.
Next, let's take a look at
the data scientist's world.
For trading firms, this area
is riddled with complexity.
You've got to acquire, ingest,
explore, and analyze the data
all before you can take action.
But Google Cloud
allows data scientists
to retrieve CME
Smart Stream data,
transform it via data
flow, and store it
in Bigtable or BigQuery.
Then, the data scientist can use
Google Cloud's AutoML platform
to train and deploy models
that predict whether a contract
price will move up or down.
As you can see, she could
store, analyze, and visualize
the results with tools
that scale, deploy,
and adapt in real time.
Finally, let's look at this from
the infrastructure engineer's
perspective.
One of the big problems
many firms face
is that inbound
financial data traverses
the public internet or a costly
private line before ingestion.
As an alternative,
Google Cloud offers
managed networking functionality
regionally and globally.
This way, the
infrastructure engineer
can connect the on-prem
or remote resources
to Google Cloud without needing
to replicate connectivity
or administrative
policies in each region.
Additionally, training
firms struggle
with keeping on-prem or even
Cloud resources up and running.
As our demo shows,
this problem could be
managed simply and effectively.
We start by leveraging
terraform descriptive
deployment of our
microservices architecture.
This architecture allows us to
containerize our application
components, while
making it easier
to support CI/CD pipelines.
Terraform enables the
automation of infrastructure
making infrastructure
easily auditable
for any governance need.
And that's it.
In this demo, we showed you how
risk managers, data scientists,
and infrastructure
engineers can easily
manage risk in the Cloud
using real-time market data.
We hope you found it useful.
For more about everything
we've talked about,
check out the links in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to our Google Cloud YouTube
channel for more great content.